gewalt schüsse und folter brutal
knüppelt das militär die ausschreitungen
und demonstrationen in kasachstan nieder
die menschen sind dort friedlich auf die
straße gegangen anfang des jahres es
ging zunächst um die für sie
unbezahlbaren gaspreise und dann um
einen protest gegen die regierung
insgesamt ja und sie haben das grab
schon gesehen das regime dort das hat
mit brutaler härte reagiert hat das
militär aufmarschieren lassen
mittlerweile tote in den straßen dort
mindestens 10.000 festnahm und unser
reporter paul ronzheimer der ist dort
nach diesen festnahmen auf der straße
dort in almaty ist jetzt paul ronzheimer
einmal die einem der mittlerweile
gefährlichsten orte der welt muss man
sagen das hat sich dort in den letzten
tagen getan paul erzähle uns von dem was
hinter den kulissen passiert
ich stehe hier in den straßen von almaty
und das hinter mir ist eines der gebäude
das so vollkommen zerstört wurde ähnlich
wie das parlament diese schäden sieht
man hier an ganz vielen ecken aber nicht
nur das ich hatte die möglichkeit mit
menschen zu sprechen die mir erzählt
haben was wirklich passiert ist die
regierung sagt das waren alles banditen
terroristen dschihadisten die wahrheit
ist es gab eine menge friedliche
demonstranten die versucht haben
aufzubegehren gegen die regierung die
auch auf der straße sein wollten und
wenn man sich hier mit den menschen
unterhält dann erfährt man wie viele
einfach festgenommen wurden wir waren
vor einem leichenschauhaus wo die
menschen nicht wussten sind meine
verwandten tod oder leben sie noch den
vielleicht nur in anführungszeichen fest
menschenrechtsaktivisten sagen dass dort
holt da kommen sie nicht rein sie werden
nicht eingelassen und ich hatte die
möglichkeit heute morgen mit us pass
spiel zu sprechen ein 32-jähriger mann
der mir erzählt hat was ihm passiert er
war in einem bus während dieser zeit ist
dann von polizisten raus gezerrt worden
aus diesem bus auf eine polizeiwache
gebracht wurden und dann brutal
geschlagen wird stocker der polizei und
er hat eine berichte wie neben ihnen
anderen demonstranten plastiktüten über
den kopf gezogen wurden und sie kaum
noch luft bekommen haben und er sagt er
hat klare folter stattgefunden
die lage scheint jetzt ruhiger paul
unterstützende truppen die ziehen
abläuft dieser frieden was berichten die
menschen vor ort
die menschen haben vor allem eines angst
viele haben auch angst vor der kamera zu
sprechen denn sie haben gesehen wie ihre
regierung durchhalten kann die truppen
bahn hier um ein zeichen der stärke
zeigen damit hat russland am ende
wladimir putin auch nachts demonstriert
er ist jetzt hier auch in kasachstan
sehr involviert dann gab es den
machtkampf zwischen den verschiedenen
truppen aber uns bald bild uns
interessiert ja wie es den normalen
menschen geht wie sie das empfinden und
da sagen ganz viele wir haben jetzt
angst weiter auf die straße gehen denn
es kann jederzeit überall etwas passiert
jetzt hast du paul putin gerade schon
angesprochen welche rolle spielt er da
jetzt in dieser aktuellen
auseinandersetzung
bleibt mir butina truppen geschickt
willicher weise wäre ohne diese truppen
das hier nicht niedergeschlagen zu lesen
da gab es ja diesen internen machtkampf
zwischen dass er bald den ehemaligen
machthaber und ca dem präsidenten nun
dadurch dass er hier diese truppen rhein
geschickt hat bedeutet auch man schuldet
ihm etwas und am ende ist es gut ihn
wieder ein zeichen dass große
sowjetreiches komm zurück zu mir und
gleichzeitig neben biederkeit wie
gleichzeitig er im ukraine in der
ukraine weiter feuer legt da gibt es
warnungen vor einem neuen krieg der dort
drohen könnte und putin legt feuer hier
an allen orten danke paul für deine
reportage aus kasachstan einem ganz
neuen blutigen hotspot im moment hier in
der welt danke dir